hey remember when rogue one trailers
came out on the internet win oh we
figured out who Ray's mom is do we have
any updates on that yeah it might be
time to rethink that one
[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film theory
the show that knows the chances of one
of my Star Wars theories successfully
navigating the asteroid field of the
Internet our 3,720 to 1 but you know
what just can't help myself you know
loyal theorists it takes a big man to
admit when he's wrong and yeah I've been
kinda wrong once or twice when it comes
to Star Wars evil Luke and force awakens
steer right one rogue one squadron
turning into the Knights of Ren yeah
that was a big right too although that
one right wiser man might have learned
his lesson by now but if I was really
that wise I probably wouldn't know in
the prequels on blu-ray dont you judge
me it's for the sake of completeness
anyway with star wars season just around
the corner and the recent release of the
last Jedi's official trailer I am in
full Star Wars hype mode I'm happier
than a poor Ginn whatever pours in joy I
don't know it's just a new creature
designed to sell toys a pork plush and a
target retailer near you
anyway I recently rewatched the force
awakens and after I breathed my sigh of
relief that no Gungans had found their
way into it cuz you never can tell with
these movies I was struck by how many
questions it leaves open who is snow why
did the first order build a giant Death
Star with essentially the same weakness
as the original Death Star
what is that insta bread that Rey makes
for dinner and where can I get some
because it looks delicious but seriously
the biggest question has to be Rey
herself who the heck is this girl it's a
question the internet latched on to in
the aftermath of this movie and it's one
that we all know is going to be answered
by the last Jedi so if I'm gonna put my
theory hat into the ring I better do it
now who are raised parents the Internet
has explored this one to its fullest I
think if I look hard enough I could
probably find someone who claims that
she's the daughter of c-3po and a Jawa
but today I'm gonna prove to you which
is the correct choice in fact I am so
confident in this theory that I'm gonna
say spoiler alert right here yeah
spoiler alert for a movie that has not
been released yet I don't necessarily
believe all my theories but today I
think I have this one nail and I think
by the end of this episode you're gonna
agree with me too so make sure you stay
through the whole episode then let me
know at the end in the comments if you
think that I got it now dust off your
sensible sweaters and DNA test kits
ladies and gentlemen
Matt Povich is here to tell some of
these dudes that you are not to begin
let's establish the details we know
about Rey that'll help us reach our
conclusion one she was left on jakku as
a small girl and hasn't seen her family
since - she's a talented pilot even a
natural and three she speaks with a
British accent despite receiving no
training that we know of anyway she's
able to use a lightsaber and Jedi
mind-trick a stormtrooper suggesting
that she is four incredibly sensitive to
the force five Luke's lightsaber calls
were in maz kanata's castle and six
let's remember that classic George Lucas
quote that the Star Wars story is quote
like poetry
it rhymes so we need a lineage that not
only fits the characteristics we know
about Rey but also the thematic elements
of the saga in general ok with our main
criteria established let's make a case
for bachelor number one from what I can
tell the Internet's current and bedding
favourite Luke Skywalker a lot of
parallels here are pretty obvious ray
and Luke both grew up on desert planets
raised by people other than their
parents they both join up with Han Solo
and then battle against a family member
remember
kylo Ren would be raised cousin if she's
Luke's daughter who offers to teach them
in the ways of the dark side so you
definitely have a big checkmark in that
whole rhyming story category then you
have the fact that Luke's lightsaber
calls to rage seeming to suggest a
family bond or shared unity know even
though ray and Luke don't talk to each
other at the end of the force awakens we
do get some interesting tidbits from the
screenplay whoa he looks at Rey behind
this in his eyes but there's something
tortured - he doesn't need to ask her
who she is or what she's doing there his
look says it all into play I know the
force is strong with Luke and all but
some girl just finds him while he's
brooding on a cliff and he doesn't need
to ask her who she is that probably
means he recognizes her which he would
if she were his long-lost daughter this
is also supported by the crucial line
used in trailers for force awakens force
is strong in my family my father hasn't
if I have it my sister has
you have that power too it definitely
seems like this is something Luke would
be saying to Rey and if that's the case
he would be implicitly looping Rey into
his family as yet another strong force
user we even get a few hints from
outside the movies had a panel
discussion with the cast of The Force
awakens Mark Hamill teased the
relationship by saying I see my duck I
mean my colleague Daisy no it's
absolutely possible that Grampy
Skywalker is just trolling the audience
but there is such a thing as hiding in
plain sight but maybe the best clue we
get comes from Kathleen Kennedy
president of Lucasfilm who gave an
interview to the Costco connection in
October 2015 in which she stated quote
the Saga films by what she means the
original trilogy the prequels and now
the new trilogy focus on the Skywalker
family saga end quote now while I'm
generally skeptical of the things I read
in newspapers printed by stores that
sell 30 pound buckets of mayonnaise this
is pretty hard to ignore if we're saying
that episode 7 8 & 9 are about the
Skywalker's and that the story rhymes it
makes plenty of sense that Rey would
take the torch from Luke as his daughter
but as the Internet's pointed out this
is far from the only possible
explanation if you want to talk about
force-sensitive loners living on desert
planets well then meet bachelor number 2
obi-wan Kenobi that lightsaber that
called to Rey let's not forget that
before it was Luke's it was Obi Wan's
and when Rey has her force vision we
hear the voices of both Alec Guinness
and you and McGregor the two actors
who've played obi-wan also Rey speaks
with a British accent if she's a
Skywalker it's hard to say where that
would have come from if she's descended
from the Kenobi's well no explanation
necessary and then when it comes to pure
Jedi style Rey closes her eyes when
she's in a lightsaber duel just like
obi-wan did she even uses Obi Wan's
famous Jedi mind-trick as one of her
first realizations of her powers true
this would mean that Rey isn't exactly
part of the Skywalker saga that Kathleen
Kennedy mentioned but how interesting
would it be for the series to go from a
Kenobi training a Skywalker to a
Skywalker then training a Kenobi
certainly fits that hold rhyme test that
George Lucas mentioned alright alright
it's time to get serious it's not my job
here to hand out gold stars and praise
everyone's theories it's my job to get
one problem with Rey being Luke's
daughter or Obi Wan's granddaughter is
that it's against Jedi rules in the
doctrine of the Jedi Order teaching
number four is that Jedi are wary of
attachments both material and personal a
lot of the other quote unquote clues
that we just covered can be explained
away pretty easily as well the British
accent thing maybe ray just picked that
up from Boone Carr plot the guy she was
just left with when she was a small
child I mean just listen to him what you
brought me today is worth one quarter
portion and sure it's true that Luke's
lightsaber called turay and that obi
wan's voice is heard during her force
vision but she also sees darth vader and
here's Yoda if anything she's being
called by the force not a specific
family member so now let's consider a
quote from Daisy Ridley herself after
the force awakens had opened timeout
London asked her about her character's
backstory
she answered by saying quote I thought a
lot was answered in the force awakens
then after the screening I went for a
drink with my agent and everyone and we
were chatting away and I realized that
Oh in their minds it's not answered at
all consider this if Daisy Ridley
thought a lot had been answered in
episode 7 then we're probably looking
for more than just a voice in a dream or
a knowing look on a cliffside so I
rewatched the movie and here's a line
that's stuck with me kylo Ren has just
captured Rey and is keeping her captive
after mentioning that he doesn't know
what happened to her friends he says
with what sounds like genuine surprise
you screw on aku still as in wanted to
kill you before kylo Ren and Rey just
met but he seems to know who she is
based on his reaction to first hearing
about her the two were accompanied by a
girl
what girl how would he know about this
random desert planet girl and how
powerful she is unless they had shared a
common past does kylo Ren know Rae
already because she's his sister yes
han Solo you are the father Wow he did
not take that well at all but seriously
all the pieces fit look at everything
that we've covered today if she's the
daughter of Leia that's where her force
powers are coming from that means that
she's Luke's niece and that lightsaber
is still a family heirloom that would be
calling out to her we never get a good
explanation as to why Rey was stashed
away on jakku but looked back at Luke's
quote from the last Jedi trailer
I've seen this frost recently once
before the two scared me enough that it
touched me in the middle of it we see
his hand emerge from under some burning
rubble followed by an image of what we
can assume as the Jedi Temple that kylo
Ren destroys it's certainly possible
that the kind of raw strength Luke saw
before and didn't fear was kylos if han
and leia realized that her older brother
was suddenly becoming very powerful and
very evil they might want to get her
away from his influence ie
hiding her out on jakku thinking of
trailer moments that line from the force
awakens trailer about the force being
strong in Luke's family still applies
here it's just now he's saying it to his
niece instead of his daughter the
British accent could come from unkar
plots or maybe just from her mother's
oddly inconsistent British tones in
Episode four the more you tighten your
grip talk of star system skin to your
fingers episode seven eight-nine can
still continue the Skywalker saga as
Kathleen Kennedy put it by following Rey
and the new trilogy can still rhyme with
the original to force using siblings who
were separated as children become
reunited with one having to save the
other the one who lived on an isolated
desert planet is mentored by an old Jedi
jesso happens to tweet pictures of
himself on her back in a clear allusion
to the Yoda Luke relationship from the
Empire Strikes Back oh yeah and that
whole natural pilot thing had to have
gotten something from her father yeah
see that is all six of our criteria
covered and there is still more if you
are still not convinced don't worry cuz
I saved the best for last here are three
deep dive pieces of evidence that are
gonna sell you on this theory number one
in one of the
we're Mark Hamill tease the audience
about Rey being his daughter he
mentioned that at the initial table read
of the force awakens seating was
assigned and that rather than being
seated next to him Daisy Ridley was in
between Harrison Ford and Carrie Fisher
now for those of you who don't know
table reads are structured to seat you
closest to the people your character
shares the closest or most important
relationships with she shares a lot of
scenes with Han Solo so sitting next to
Harrison Ford makes sense but Leia not
so much and especially squeezing her in
between the two of them is awfully
strange if she's not in some way related
to them point number two actress Billie
lourd who plays the bit role of
Lieutenant conics in the force awakens
originally auditioned for the role of
Rey why is that fishy
because Billie lourd happens to be
Carrie Fisher's real-life daughter if
you're looking to establish a family
resemblance casting mother and daughter
as mother and daughter ought to do it
and here's the biggest number three the
meme tastic hug that Leia gives ray
after Han is killed Leia walks right
past Chewbacca who she's known for
decades and who was Hans partner for
longer than that instead going straight
to comforting brave a girl she would
have never met before there's a reason
why the internet ripped into this moment
it's insane it's stupid it's silly until
you consider that Leia might be Ray's
mother and looking at the screenplay
gives us even greater cause for
suspicion whoa the two women move for
each other and Leia takes a raised face
in her hands
despite her heartbreak she's grateful
she embraces Rey a mother's embrace
huh interesting choice of words there
but hey that's just a theory a film
theory and may the force be with you
these are not the droids you're looking
for this is the subscribe button you
were looking for this is the subscribe
button you are planning on clicking
because with the Star Wars TV show
coming out yeah that's news if you
haven't heard that one you'll want to
make sure you're up to date on all the
latest theories about the universe so
click it it's not a trap